il y à des individus il ya des quartiers
qui sont hors la loi dans notre pays et
ça c'est une réalité d'aujourd'hui c'est
l'échec du président de la république
actuel le principal échec c'est celui de
la sécurité de ce sentiment d'impunité
d'insécurité qui règne partout pas
seulement dans les quartiers à marseille
ou dans la région parisienne et dans
beaucoup de campagnes il faut interroger
les français et ça c'est une
responsabilité à laquelle le président
sortant monsieur mac ou n'échappera pas
à la situation et il faut bien la
comprendre et la regarder de l'est j'ai
ouvert ce sont 2000 agressions par jour
ce sont 100 agressant directement contre
des hommes et des femmes qui ont une
autorité publique des policiers des
gendarmes des professeurs des élus
locaux des sapeurs pompiers ça suffit ce
qu'a voulu dire alain perez sait qu'elle
a décidé de faire une vraie politique
pour mettre fin à cette insécurité
rétablir les moyens dans la justice a
besoin rétabliront peut pas parler ça ne
peut pas faire le en même temps on avait
monsieur marc roy a fiché un un t-shirt
contre les violences policières et puis
reçu un autre jour défendre les
policiers on a besoin d'une petite
d'autorité c'est ça qu'il a voulu dire à
léry pécresse et je suis à ses côtés
pour le dire et pour le faire nous
allons assumer une politique de droite
une petite d'autorité pour rétablir la
sécurité publique le présent république
pour reprendre un mot qu'il a utilisée
de mon point de vue de manière assez
injuste à l'égard des français
il est responsable c'est lui qui est
responsable
il est responsable de l'effondrement de
notre commerce extérieur il était
responsable de l'explosion de notre
dette et de notre déficit il est
responsable du chômage il est
responsable de l'insécurité et il
n'échappera pas à cette responsabilité
ça va être l'objet de la campagne
présidentielle que de souligner cette
responsabilité et puis de dire ce que
nous allons faire